hey guys how's it going it's Justine and
today we are testing out the new a7 3 by
Sony I'm super excited about this
because I've been such a huge Sony fan
for the past couple of years I use two
cameras in my unboxing setup and that's
the a7s2 so I'm excited to get my hands
on this thing and try it out one of the
things that has already noticeably made
my life so much better is the increase
in the battery sizes so this is the npf
z100 battery hold on a comparison this
is used in the a7s2 and the 6500 that I
use and this is the a7 3 battery this is
also using the a7 r3 in addition to
having better battery life you can also
shoot longer because there's now a dual
SD card slots there's an all new menu
system and if you guys are huge fans of
the PlayMemories app store that is no
longer a thing I used to use that all
the time to do time lapses so there is a
small workaround that you can use the s
and Q setting you can go in there and
you can turn your frame right down to
one which in theory will give you a very
simple solution to do easy time lapses
anyway I'm in Hawaii and my sister and I
are going to go to the beach and fly
some drones so let's test this camera
and take it with us and see how it does
on its first trip out in the wild the
other thing the record button placement
is different it used to be on the side
and now it's kind of in the back and on
the middle so that I need to get used to
just to you think oh my gosh it's so
much heavier I'm using a 24 to 105 lens
so it does a little bit zoomed in on my
face but I'm so used to my a 6500 and
the really tiny lens it's like going
from this to this it's heavy I had to
fake open the door for the shot Jen
obviously don't you know how this works
[Music]
we were out on a little walk I was just
testing out the 120 frames a second and
at some Q settings it's pretty awesome
because I can just switch for my movie
mode back to that again so it makes it
very easy to switch between slow-mo and
regular moe regular moe
how do you feel about regular Moe that's
my favorite Mel
[Music]
[Applause]
here's the problem the Sun sets on the
opposite side of the island we're just
gonna try to fly our drones really quick
and I'm also gonna test out the
time-lapse option on here even the s and
Q feature and we'll be setting the
intervals to one so let's see how it
looks
[Music]
we got some new great drone shots
I also took my first photo with his
camera Oh Jenna am I allowed to use the
photos of you Jenna Jenna approved
photos but man I'm so excited for this
camera Jen can take a few photos of me
the stuff will test out that low-light
[Music]
we are off on a hike today we're going
to Diamond Head it's one of the most
popular hikes I feel like on this island
I also switched up my microphone a
little bit because the one that I was
using before this rode microphone have a
feeling that this got crushed in transit
because the sound coming out of the
first part of this video it sounded
really tinny and canny so I think
something might be wrong with this I'm
so sad
we're playing a game called can we get
there without GPS I hate this game
because yesterday when we played it we
almost didn't make it home yesterday
didn't work out so well but today I've
got I've got a better feeling product
this game isn't gonna go well
don't wait wait a map no no we need to
figure it out there's something happens
and there's a Citian apocalypse EMP EMP
and we're like oh god I gotta get to
Diamond Head and then you gotta use your
brain if there was an EMP you the place
that we would be going is not in the
middle of a crater why no I'm talking
why would you bother to go there well
where would you go I would probably just
stay in the house
oh you're boring so this is Diamond Head
Jenna and I did this hike a long time
ago it might have been around oh I don't
remember
Tina actually I think 2013 it's been a
pretty long time you probably look back
on a YouTube video I remember somebody
saw that I took a picture here and they
ran up the mountain to find us and got a
picture with us it was like such a crazy
surreal moment Oh like how did you find
us like you posted a picture hey so now
we gotta go through this tunnel
this is our third attempt to do this
hike first time that we came here the
park actually closes at six o'clock but
they only take the last people in at
4:30 and then we tried to go the other
day and it was so busy that we could
even find a place to park where there
were so many people that I don't think
it would have been an enjoyable
experience
[Music]
font why would you scoop iris
having flashbacks in Austria and we went
down that random tunnel we've got two
options to get to the top we've got this
one which is a little bit wide here and
then one that goes a straight up I think
we're gonna take the wine do one first
Jenna lost Jenna already
I remember this is there a shot and a
sky J video right here I had like the
camera mounted somewhere on one of these
pools
it is extremely bright which is not good
for filming and I don't have an ND
filter on this camera the climb we made
it all the way to the top I was testing
out this new other camera it doesn't
really prove 360 videos I'll do a video
on that later but this is all about ASA
3 and our phone trip to the top here
feminist it's really beautiful
there's so many people here now you
definitely have to come and do this like
earlier or you can see super crowded
jenna is freaking out back there why is
one of my favorite places ever it's just
so beautiful every place that you go
it's just stunning with amazing views
and now we are about to hop on a boat
and go out to a sandbar
I also brought how many drunks we afford
Rome had a lot of drones for drones
several cameras I definitely come way
too prepared with tech and sometimes
takes away from the beauty of traveling
and experiencing things in real life I
do really enjoy editing and then going
back and reliving the fund this is so
pretty where are we yep
that's what we are
great take on Wow it is like a perfect
day but I'm so exhausted because we did
the Koko Head crater hike today and it
is like a thousand steps up and it hells
and steps down I post an Instagram story
about it
[Music]
we are going golf and we are at a really
room beautiful Golf Course and the only
size shirts that they have our large I
think it'll look good good luck
I mean should I go get myself a shirt
that fits know how fortun like I said
that's all we got left
it's all good oh gosh okay I think Susie
you're gonna have to but all right okay
[Music]
okay making Justine Drive do I go down
this hole
number 10 t go right towards hot Tori
okay okay I'm I'm flooring it right now
Cameron's heavy it is a wonderful day
here in Oahu and what better place to
celebrate a wonderful beautiful day than
golfing you guys don't know I am
basically a professional golfer
I have golf probably four times in my
entire life last time that I set foot on
a golf course I was dressed in a mermaid
costume and it was seven years ago I'm
not proud of it but man that video was
really funny and super embarrassing to
watch now don't drive on the tee boxes
we got to find our balls
so I'm at the wall really wonderful
thing that's basically the entire point
of golf but then I couldn't find it
so we decided just to move along what's
that All American Rejects all
that one genna's up now you got this
Jenna be a champion do this for do it
for tiger
[Music]
next crash I wasn't good
maybe I just don't like this club it's
just not sized right from my body
[Music]
go go go get it go go go we need those
very important
[Music]
whoa whoa
I think I hit a house Oh Oh No
Zak heart dead what happened go it
wasn't on Oh got to get out of here guys
we are done that's it I think we have
two more holes left foot we gotta go to
sunset
[Music]
that elicits a sunset I hope that my
drone was working okay because I just
did a firmware update and for some
reason it wasn't letting me focus I
don't know if that's a Matic error thing
but I'm gonna look into it
but for now we're gonna go get some
dinner and that is it for today I'm
exhausted
that's unfurnished we really did
[Music]
these were by the crawl